all right time for a local real estate
update what's the june market looking
like i spoke to palacios really to find
out
it's great to see you and get an update
on this crazy real estate market we have
here locally let's talk specifically
about the june market what's going on
right so
we are in june here in vegas it's
summertime it's hot we have excessive
heat warnings
but we don't in real estate and so uh
that's kind of a good thing because
while our
median price point is just a little
north of 375
we still have a shortage of inventory
we're actually leveling off our numbers
were pretty equal to what they were in
april and that's the direction we want
to head so
that's the good news uh in light of
everything that we're dealing with here
on
the real estate side of things why do
you think sellers are reluctant to sell
in this particular market i mean there's
a lot of what-ifs right
what if i can't get the home i want what
if i can't get the negotiations to
secure the home i want or more
importantly
what if i can't make the move in one
time and unfortunately
it really just boils down to who you
work with if you're working with a
professional
we can navigate these challenges in fact
it's super exciting for us because
while cash is king for a lot of people
strong
offers and smart negotiations have been
our
winning bread and butter we've got
clients for the last six months who have
all closed
and did not pay out of pocket and that's
a really significant thing to say in
this market because
uh we've hear many many stories of you
know 10 20 30 out of pocket
but we've been able to be able to match
those numbers up right and get people
the win that they're looking for
just who you work with matters to
people's ears right now um
why should why should we not wait for
the market to cool off
quote unquote yeah well
it's really two answers right our
inventory is a challenge but
uh when we get back to normal i mean
it's going to it's going to create
a problem right we expect 12 to 14
months for this market to adjust
so uh while your inventory will be
available to
buy it makes the selling portion that
less
attractive so you're not going to be
able to maximize your dollars you're not
going to be able to
uh get what you're looking for as you
can in today's market the second item is
cost
it's going to take 12 to 14 months so
rates we expect to go up
as well as the cost of homes if you can
secure what you are looking for now
then you get to take advantage of the
appreciation and have a super low rate
those are the winning scenarios that
people want to have so
get a consultation talk to a
professional get your answers of what
you're looking for it's super important
okay and lastly here jerry you know
obviously cobit has been such a
rough time for everybody especially in
the real estate market
and we have a special offer to tell
everybody about in regards to that
yes yes the the pandemic has affected
many folks and unfortunately a lot of
them have been
caught off guard we've had many
situations where parents have passed
and they did not have any sort of will
or any preparations in place so
what we'd like to bring awareness to our
community is if you're thinking about
buying or selling
and you do that here with velocio's
realty we will cover the cost of an
estate planning package where you can
either have your will or your trust or
your living trust all set up we will
cover those costs for you
with the relationships we have we'd love
to be able to share that with those who
really really need it
such a generous offer there give
palacios realty a call at 702-333-6666
and check out their special offer again
here it is mention this segment while
buying or selling with palacios realty
for covered cost of their estate
planning package we'll be right back
right here